apprendre à calculer l'âge de l'univers
en anglais le lycée jules ferry a
accueilli miles oddsson un professeur de
sciences physiques britannique pour un
atelier d'astronomie
c'est un programme du british concile
l'idée est de donner plus de regrets aux
étudiants mais pas seulement des cours
d'anglais
on suppose qu'il est plus intéressant
pour eux d'apprendre l'anglais sans
savoir qu'on apprend l'anglais
les premières s sections européennes ont
également pu déchiffrer les messages
adressés aux extraterrestres on était
vraiment acteur on faisait juste
l'ex-top il y avait des ateliers en
rythme annuel qu'on n'a pas encore
normal s'explique en anglais
donc moi au début je pensais ne pas trop
comprendre mais finalement c'était le
british council services britanniques
pour les relations culturelles à
l'international propos son programme
saillant this could depuis dix ans le
principe faire venir un enseignant
britannique pour donner un atelier
scientifique aux élèves et dirigé une
master class avec les professeurs c'est
l'occasion aussi à plat de faire des
échanges collaboratifs qu'on espère
après
durée sur un plus long terme et pourquoi
pas ne pas le réinviter l'année
prochaine ou pour d'autres sessions sur
d'autres sujets très intéressant
l'académie de versailles a accueilli ces
ateliers dans quatre établissements
différents